uh let me ask you about a competitor
and somebody's become a friend
so Elon Musk Contessa have announced
have been in the early days of building
a humanoid robot how does that change
the landscape of
uh of your work so there's sort of from
the outside perspective it seems like
well from a fan as a fan of Robotics it
just seems exciting all right very
exciting right when when Elon speaks
people listen
and so uh it suddenly brought a bright
light onto the work that we've been
doing you know for over a decade
and
um and I think that's only going to help
and in fact what we've seen is that in
addition to Tesla uh we're seeing a
proliferation of uh robotic companies
arise now including humanoid yes oh well
yeah so and um interestingly many of
them uh as they're you know raising
money for example will claim whether or
not they have a former Boston Dynamics
employee on their staff as a criteria
yeah that's true that's uh I I I would
do that as a company yeah for sure yeah
so it shows you're legit yeah yeah so
you know what it's bring it has brung a
tremendous validation to what we're
doing
and excitement uh competitive juices are
flowing you know the whole thing so uh
it's all good
Elon is also
kind of
stated
that uh
you know maybe he implied that the
problem is solvable in the near term
which is a low-cost humanoid robot
that's able to do that's a relatively
General use case robot
so um I think Elon is known for sort of
setting these kinds of incredibly
ambitious goals
maybe missing deadlines but actually
pushing not just the particular team he
leads but the entire world
to like accomplishing those do you see
you see Boston Dynamics in the near
future being pushed in that kind of way
like this excitement of competition kind
of
um
pushing Atlas maybe to uh do more cool
stuff trying to drive the cost of Atlas
down perhaps or um I mean I guess I want
to I want to ask if there's
some kind of exciting
energy in Boston Dynamics
due to this a little bit of competition
oh yeah definitely
um when we released our most recent
video of Atlas you know I think you'd
seen it scaffolding and throwing the box
of Tools around and then doing the flip
at the end yeah we were trying to show
the world that not only can we do this
parkour Mobility thing but we can pick
up and move heavy things
because uh if you're going to work in a
manufacturing environment that's what
you got to be able to do
and for the reasons I explained to you
earlier it's not trivial to do so you
know changing the center of mass uh uh
you know by picking up a 50 pounds block
you know for a robot that weighs 150
pounds
that's a lot to accommodate so we're
trying to show that we can do that
and
um so it's totally been energizing you
know we see
the next phase of Atlas being more
dexterous hands that can manipulate and
grab more things that we're going to
start by moving big things around that
are heavy and that affect balance and
why is that well really tiny dexterous
things probably are going to be hard for
a while yet and you know maybe you could
go build a special purpose
robot arm you know for for stuffing you
know chips into Electronics boards but
we don't really want to do really fine
work like that I think more coursework
where you're using two hands to pick up
and balance an unwieldy thing maybe in a
manufacturing environment maybe in a
construction environment those are the
things that we think robots are going to
be able to do with the level of
dexterity that they're going to have in
the next few years and that's the that's
where we're headed and and I think and
you know Elon has seen the same thing
right he's talking about using the
robots in a manufacturing environment we
think there's something very interesting
there about having this this a two-armed
robot because when you have two arms you
can transfer a thing from one hand to
the other you can turn it around you
know you can you can reorient it in a
way that you can't do it if you just
have one hand on it and so there's a lot
that extra arm brings to the table so I
think in terms of mission
you you mentioned Boston Dynamics really
wants to see what are the what's the
limits of what's possible and so the
cost comes second
or it's a component but first figure out
what are the limitations I think with
Elon he's really driving the cost down
is there some inspiration some lessons
you see there
um of the challenge of driving the cost
down especially with Atlas with a
humanoid robot well I think the thing
that he's certainly been learning by
building car factories is what that
looks like in scaling
um by scaling you can get efficiencies
that drive costs down very well and uh
and the smart thing that you know they
have in their favor is that you know
they know how to manufacture they know
how to build electric motors they know
how to build uh you know computers and
vision systems so there's a lot of
overlap between modern
Automotive companies and robots
but hey
we have a modern robotic I mean that
automotive company behind us as well
so uh bring it on who's doing pretty
well right the electric vehicles from
Hyundai are doing pretty well